yes I want to get into I want to talk to
I want to respond to that Chris D'Elia
you know him and he's really my god
dude if you've ever I mean if you've
ever had something just if you ever had
your shadow someone you'll see if you're
standing outside and you look next to
yourself there's something real dark
right there and that's not a you know
this isn't a racial thing or anything
it's your shadow and if you ever seen
your shadow sometime if you look over
real fast you'll see it you know doing
something there doing something naughty
you know maybe looking at a nudie
magazine or you know doing one of them
clothes cigarette you know we're doing
something real nasty or something or
touching his little dark little Weiner
and that's Chris D'Elia right there you
know he lives on the north side of a
tree you know what I'm saying he's that
he's that uh he's that he's the dark art
and he's a dark art man and he came at
me brother he came at me and uh and I
want to talk about that right here I
want to play here's a clip of what he
said right here oh I also want to talk
about this one more thing before we go
so Theo my buddy my arch-nemesis on this
podcast thing made fun of me for
canceling a show because of cuz you did
because I couldn't get there literally
couldn't get this you know what actually
let me say this man
I will never cancel the show cool here's
what things although that's a great
sound bite that's a great sound but see
what he's doing here I have some news
for you
Theo didn't cancel the show Theo
canceled his whole European tour
oh me too before it happened because he
got a movie so not only did he do what
he said he would never do how he's doing
the same thing I'm doing I would never
do that what he's doing
who's the stepdad now and who's the real
daddy did he was what was he okay okay
that's enough first of all Chris D'Elia
wears deodorant on his whole arm okay so
people should know that that he start
at the wrists with the stick and brings
it all the way up to the pit so that
right there that's something you know I
want to say this has crystal you ever
eaten a egg sandwich that he cooked the
egg on the top of a hot Ford has he uh
no have I yes as Chris D'Elia ever
battled rare diseases and beat him or
tied them even oh no but have I done it
yes has Chris D'Elia ever fought a guy
in a sharp dragon suit outside of a JC
Penney's when he was younger and beat
the guy you know to you know to to two
to one rounds oh no
but have I done it oh yes is crystally a
gated community gangster oh yes he is
has he ever lived next door to an adult
video store that also sold shrimp okay
and still managed his emotions well even
though sometimes he was you know you
know pleasuring himself but also you
know there's horseradish in the area you
feel me okay oh no have I yes
would I ever cancel a show because of
weather no oh yes you will not find me
postponed in a show because of the air
elements okay storm rain fire second
coming third coming case Jesus gets lost
you feel me
sunlight no light drizzle missiles
drizzles ice missiles I will be there
bring it on mother nature and will
crystal you be there no will I be there
yes so I'm the real daddy all right if
you put my Johnson on a record player
and played it backwards you can hear it
go Danny Danny
Neddy cuz I got that Bose surround pound
you feel me
what's that I hear someone coming up the
steps yeah it's the step daddy cause a
little bit and the real daddy is the one
that brings home the metal bacon baby
you feel man that is home just so
everybody knows what's going on around
here
did you enjoy that clip well you really
would have enjoyed it if he was watching
on a TCL TV TCL is America's
fastest-growing TV brand it's so fast
it's the Carl Lewis of television brands
it's that Florence Griffith visual
jointer
it's celebrating its fifth anniversary
from launching in the US markets I have
one of these at home and these suckers
are just I mean it's like having a Mona
Lisa on your wall that plays everything
you want follow TCL at TCL underscore
USA on Twitter and Instagram for more
details for more information about TCL
visit TCL usa.com
that's TCL usa.com